what I'm gonna do is slowly apply some
pressure and I want you to tell me if
you can breathe okay
how can you breathe yep and let me make
my case here what do you guys think of
chokehold especially people who've never
actually had one applied to them or used
it at all because we're going to
actually do it I don't think Wade's ever
been now oh this is good I won't lie
neck restraint sounds more harmless
here's what I'll say it's more
uncomfortable than a neck restraint but
less unpleasant than you would assume a
chokehold would be hmm
but you might be let's go on to the
chokehold and I've been so upset about
this I have a pit in my stomach because
this man is facing death doesn't matter
what charges you think I'm more upset
with by the way the Christian
conservative right because you know what
I'll just pray from the farm you know
there's a man who could be put to death
neutrality is not an option that's not
an option right now okay people you see
this in all this you know Los Angeles
and California New York and like well
you know what Jesus is just love Jesus
flipped over some tables and if you want
to save a life you can speak out and
help save a life right now because by
all accounts we have a code change
tomorrow a good man could be put to
death to appease a mob of evil people
yeah if good men don't step in and you
know what if you don't step in now when
the wolves are at the door expect us to
love you and pray for you from afar but
we're gonna go lock lock lock lock bolt
stand up and grow a pair by the way that
includes Donald Trump yeah that goes all
the Republican bootlickers at this point
right now there were riots before we
elected you and there are riots worse
now do something because I don't know
the user to anyone's votes at this point
okay let's let's go into the executive
order on chokehold which of course no
one in this administration actually know
what they are talking about it appears
as part of this new credentialing
process choke calls will be banned
except if an officer's life is at risk
how do you determine that and I will say
we've dealt with all of the various
departments and everybody said it's time
we have to do it so then in this
scenario in Atlanta the officers
couldn't have used a chokehold
because they were they weren't even
under threat of bodily injury according
to the DA that that's the craziest part
about is you have to ignore all of the
physical attack and they call it
tussling right it's tussling that's
those boys got into a hootenanny you had
you have to ignore the reality of the
situation and the facts that are shown a
video to say that there wasn't a threat
of physical violence in that yeah and
please always need better physical
training we'll talk about how to do that
with Rocco well again let me be really
clear a choke well people get this wrong
like oh my gosh choke hold is like
drowning and I'm going to display it
later on wait here in a couple of
minutes it's not at all and and you can
you can understand that really quickly
just by seeing how quickly a choke hold
or a neck restraint it's a vascular neck
restraint it is a term choke it's a it's
it's a blood choke it's not a windpipe
choke what we're talking about here
there are windpipe chokes but what we're
talking about vascular neck restraint do
you know okay
grounding takes a while because there's
no oxygen you can't breathe in the
oxygen right right but show Cole's
vascular networks can actually work
within seconds here's an example of Joe
Rogan from I don't know maybe 12 years
ago applying a chokehold so you can see
how quickly someone goes out no it
doesn't take it's not like drowning I
mean really it's not a plot one that's
not applied to the windpipe one that's
applied properly it impedes arterial
blood flow right let me explain it to
you in a simple way okay the brain
recognizes the arterial blood the blood
flow is compromised sends a message
going oh wait a second and the heart
starts slowing down its pulse it starts
slowing down the blood needed
effectively a choke hold is one of the
very few kinds of techniques that you
can use worse a pain hold a submission
sometimes the damage is already being
Donald um feel that if they're on PCP
they have no idea a chokehold avascular
necrosis
we put your body into standby mode so
that it prevents damage yeah so that you
don't drowned for someone of decent
health and by the way that's the same
reason you can't use tranquilizer guns
because we don't know what drugs are in
these people there's no 100% safe way
but for someone who doesn't have a
serious condition and even with people
have more serious conditions avascular
necrosis right is undoubtedly more safe
than a punch a strike a baton a Taser if
they have a pacemaker
a tranquilizer your body goes wait a
second I'm not gonna get blood I don't
want actual drowning to happen where
there's brain damage so let's shut
everything down
so this there's a little blood flow and
as little blood and a little oxygen the
blood necessary so that I can actually
sustain this that's the wonder of the
vascular nekross strings you can be put
out never hurt no damage I don't think
you can think of it people don't just
get hit and your body is like oh my gosh
I'm going to take a nap to protect you
already have concussive brain damage
yeah by the way hit this speaking of
damage hit the notification bell hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't work notifications don't work on
the YouTube we do good morning mug Club
weekdays Monday through Thursday at
10:00 a.m. Eastern and of course do join
mug club because god knows what's gonna
happen to us after this show oh I know I
know I know that they're trained
athletes but I put this on Twitter and I
think will have a LoJack oh well link
we've had it you know chill song we've
had Daniel Cormier on people who compete
in striking sports like boxing
kickboxing or likely to sustain serious
permanent injury or death right you know
you've heard about concussive syndrome
yeah just look at Muhammad ah yeah and
we have I think a source here from
academic yet and then we have another
source from PubMed we're dropping sports
chokeholds are actually much safer let
me guess
studies show that proper choke hold
taught to police rarely ever fatal
rarely even serious injuries as a matter
of fact according to the brutality spur
Talent a database run by fatal
encounters a pro police reform
organization less than 1% less than 1%
of people die from any form of
asphyxiation while under any type of
restraint during police encounters three
and a half times more people are killed
by Tasers oh so tasers are additive
tasers are significantly more dangerous
than chokehold and I understand but
these are unpleasant scenarios what you
have to do is pick an option that keeps
people as safe as
both the perp and the police officer and
there is right now an actual technique
available that can be used to render
someone entirely incapacitated without
electrocuting their heart yes or
rattling their brain around in their
skull
it is unreal to me and ask you this how
many careers have you seen ended in
boxing for mixed martial arts from a
strike in boxing it used to be I don't
know if it cleaned up is like four
deaths a year the only death I think we
didn't a sanctioned MMA bout is weight
cutting yeah but many careers have been
ended from strikes repetitive strikes
people have broken their shins right now
name me one person who's suffered
permanent damage in any professional
fighting sport sanctioned fighting sport
from a chokehold it's never happened now
now people say well it's because you tap
know you can find videos longer than you
can photo G than watching a lifetime
with people going unconscious in the
Octagon yeah now they say well referee
steps in sure that's the point of police
training exactly you don't hold the
choke for a minute if you hold it they
go out cuff them you're going take a
quick break I'm gonna come back and show
you what a chokehold what a vascular
neck restraint is like and what it is
not
all right it's gonna be a fun show what
it's done so first let me show you
something that's really uh
some of those you love this with Jocko
in a minute remember they were stopping
they grabbed the guy's taser okay so let
me show you before we go to a choke hold
right here there's a Taser you can apply
a joint lock but I want to show you what
a joint lock is so you can see how
unpleasant this is for example so let's
say I'm coming in here I grab that wrist
and I pin way this is what we know as a
Commerce's older lock Wade what you're
gonna do do you attack when you start
feeling some pain okay okay so there you
go so and I'm not in proper position
right now because they have a desk
behind us but that's unpleasant
backwards okay so now sit back up I had
to take my boots no no put your seat up
there so everyone who says is gay but
anyone's ever actually apply to choke
knows what this is
took off my shoes because I didn't want
to hit him in the balls
so typically what happens is a rear
naked choke you see this a lot in ma I'm
trying to control his body here so this
is a good establishing of control so
right let's say you try and squirm out
the whole reason I'm just controlling
your body here and you have some options
but here see I'm riding you like a
backbone yeah there's an over-under grip
now what I want to do really quickly I
don't want to choke you in the windpipe
okay so if you're uncomfortable
obviously just tackled let it go but I
want you to let me know if you can
breathe okay a lot of people think it's
like drowning what really happens is I'm
getting as crowded arteries right here
gonna be shutting down blood flow okay
and there are multiple ways to do it I
can actually do it here with his collar
this is called a bow and arrow choke so
see look at this you can even see my
forearm is not on his throat right you
can see this nut but I can cut off the
blood circulation that way there are a
million different ways but the most
common is what's called the rear naked
choke so I'm gonna do is grab wait here
okay
put this understand I don't want to get
I don't wanna get a zipper on sure yeah
you know it's better than a Taser to the
heart that's true or the balls yeah but
you Electrify my heart so wait don't
worry this segments called dog skill
we're comfortable so what I'm gonna do
here is put him in a chokehold and if
any of you have questions you can ask
I'm gonna grab my own bicep my own
shoulder the idea here is to close the
space around his neck as much as I can
so a lot of people get this wrong if
they're not trained
really what they'll do is they'll grab
this and they'll gherkin right I had one
trainer who called called this for some
reason I don't know why the Captain
America and the Wolverine I don't know
what so let me show you kind of really
quickly if you can come here man you
show let's say this is wage head right
here Carol just never one second let's
say this is Wade's head okay the goal is
to close a space
this is his throat my elbow is ideally
right where his throat is so that's the
least amount of pressure being applied
is right on his trachea if I'm doing it
correctly but I want to squeeze the
sides of his neck so here's all the
space for Wade's head right now close it
okay there's a little less space right
close that no what I do is put this on
my shoulder a little less space hit
imagine his head right near my chest
bring this around there's a little less
space something else I do breathe in
there's a little less space then I
squeeze everything together I don't yank
that's how you miss a choke that's why
you see some guys who can be choked for
a long time they don't go out what I
want to do here is get my head on this
side and close that space look at that
space right there how much space is
there for weights head not a whole lot
suing it'll actually be applied more
quickly yeah so wait what I wanted to
start applying it and I'm in a place
where my goal is not to make you go
unconscious but if it doesn't hurt you
know you don't have to tap because it's
not gonna be painful if you do go I just
wanna get rid of the zipper here now
what I'm gonna do is do me a favor since
just let's point your throat so it's
right in the Nook of my elbow right
there okay
just for right now now what I'm gonna do
is slowly apply some pressure and I want
you to tell me if you can breathe okay
now can you breathe yep you know can you
breathe now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna apply the pressure to the point
that you could go unconscious and you
can tap but I want you to tell me if
it's because you can't breathe okay yeah
tap his foot if you need to go
this yeah yeah okay he's back in good
here that wine raises feet up let's just
raise the speed up this is what we do so
we get some good blood flow back yeah do
you know that you want to conscious make
sense are you good could you brief it
was some waterboarding at all no do you
feel like you're drowning no you'd have
hurt your neck no I didn't know if she
should thank God for the audience there
you know I could I felt it in the sea
right away I kind of felt okay he's
going out sure and then happen he came
out and by the way that's not a seizure
anything that's literally his body going
out waking the power up from standby
mode you good yeah thanks for being a
champ about it nice see didn't even
drunk it by the way he would not have
been able to do that if I crush his
windpipe sure drown there's no way
that's okay I can't breathe yet and all
of us have had this done just who've
done we're doing you Jitsu so go find
your local instructor speaking which I
think we have to go to Jocko I'm gonna
buy this man a beer you know what's in
here it's just water that's why they
call it acting what it actually smells
garlicky there's something wrong with
the water I think it's going through the
icemaker we don't have we don't have the
baking soda in the fridge if you liked
this video subscribe hit notifications
or just check back every single day
because we upload a new video every
single day this was actually taken from
the full show a full hour show the way
upload every single Thursday click that
right now go watch the entire show if
you don't want to you don't you don't
have to but if you if you stop by you
know just don't bother me I'm gonna
enjoy my garlic water